dis moi alors je voulais vous dire
quelque chose il vers des zes et m'a
passionné hier c'est la liste des objets
abandonnés par les clients français dans
les taxis et vtc c'est normal top 5
ona le top 5 on numéro 5 c'est quoi
c'est comment ça va se passer
[Rires]
en fait il voulait qu'on joue à la
famille en or les deux marques garantes
de la famille en or sont les objets
oubliés dans les vtc les frères ont
sonné la page s'il vous plaît si c'est
marrant alors à votre avis allez
téléphone téléphone téléphone c'est des
objets insolites un nom insolite aux
élites insolite téléfilm que
vibromasseur ni brabham et à beinheim
justement la retrouver le boutre
[Applaudissements]
à 5 square et voilà mais naim je vous
rappelle qu'elle a adhéré c'est vrai
vous avez des briques à 9 ans ex torride
latry la maison alors oui lingerie fine
lingerie fine
non non mais alors oui des menottes des
mains béni un bébé d'à ils sont rigolos
elle fait des soirées et couscous ou non
mais je cherche dans le non mais tu
cherches un peu par hasard et la limte
toujours dans la même direction mais je
ne sépare et des biens un grand père
vous faites partie des snipers une
perruque le kabyle est rentré dans les
moeurs les méritants non mais non merci
le dentier d'isabelle annoncé lundi
zabel tu sors isabelle vouliez dire quoi
ma chérie de moi c'est sécher obligé à
j'ai oublié un jour un truc dingue
toxiques était un solide mais je suis
passé quartz dans astérix est arrivé à
rennes avec moi c'est original
ses pas de danse est pas dit non mais
des préservatifs ah bah oui mais non est
l'outil 10 à son arrêt de maintenance
devraient bientôt des préserve non pas
du tout gratuit des saint des saints le
personnel démontable mais sans réel
frais comme des personnes en kit
les grecs j'arrive cesal ils sont frais
via thema phalaris d'après la ccia j'en
ai marre et je vais bien sa mère sur la
commande figurez vous que c'est quelque
chose qui ont déjà moi même oublié c'est
que quand vous allez en soirée il existe
des choses vous avez vous coller sur les
seins saadé il faut ça je les avais
enlevé oublié depuis lors sans mon nez
taxiway bien sûr faux c'est connu à
écouter en tout cas vous donner envie -
déconner alors oui de champignons 2 c on
oublie les les délais vous m'emmerdez
que je vous le donne et casse continue
on continue c'était pas un costume de
mickey à huit vous fait rêver les trois
premiers à trouver un costume de mickey
ouais on a recommandé à trouver une
selle d'équitation ah oui on a retrouvé
une robe de mariée et elle appartenait à
une annexe de benjamin castaldi et les
trouver alors les trois premiers alors
vous dis je vous donne un indice c'est
quelque chose qui chauffe à ses cheveux
non allons tout de suite à l'eau friel à
quoi un gouffre et un radiateur tout
simplement un radiateur
on vous rappelle si vous nous rejoignez
si les objets oubliés dans les taxis et
vtc les suites objets les plus drôles en
deux il ya un mec qui a oublié je vous
dis vous trouverez jamais un caddie un
caddie en irak enfin je vous dis de
numéro 1 1 à nice n'ont pas d'indicés il
regarde quelqu'un qui oublie son
pacemaker n'est pas loin quand pour des
dépenses et un anus artificiel
[Applaudissements]
nous déçoit jamais
à partir du 15 m eur merci merci merci
merci